and then from Nerlens while hosting SNL  Ryan Gosling can't get through any of  his live sketches without breaking it  happens again and again and yeah again  and after laughing the night away Ryan  hits up the after-party making a rare  public appearance with Ava Mendez  there's jay-z and beyonce making a swift  exit from the party after Jayde served  as a show's musical guest  [Music]  Leslie Jones is clearly a fan snagging  selfies with both of the Carters and  it's even date night for Scarlett  Johansson and her new recorded boyfriend  Colin joke keeping things quiet Colin  and Scarlett makes separate entrances  into the party